it's my 26th hu hu is my favorite
convention every year y'all come just
right around Christmas and we're festive
as all get-out it's the only convention
that thinks adults know whether they can
drink and pay attention or not every
other convention assumes that if you
have a beer your brain goes soft but not
to geophysicist they think if you have a
beer you can still learn things so they
do they come they have a beer they go
talk to the poster sessions they go host
of post-recession
they go back to class it's treating
people like adults as opposed to
children I'm all for it I definitely
think that there is a tighter link
between geologists severe and other
Sciences I am
discussed this actually would IPM and so
forth and all they can think about is
geology and beer and so other scientists
are making those observations as well
definitely the most beer consumed by
geologists I think because there's a
acceptance in the community that it's
okay to drink beer at meetings I mean
we're at a we're at a professional
meeting and they're serving a spear at
four o'clock in the afternoon I think
there is something that about the way
that a lot of geologists are trained
where it becomes part of the culture
that it's around a lot when you're doing
field work or you're camping or you're
so fun coming back from meetings or been
hiking and collecting samples all day
it's refreshing it's available it's
inexpensive you can take a camping with
you because it comes in aluminum cans
and it's tasty basically it's because
we're out in bush and a long periods of
time and we need to quench our thirst
and
it just it just comes naturally alright
here's the answers because we're like
free flow of information my ideas about
in science is all about 3/4 of
inventions so science doesn't work when
people keep secrets and don't share
their data so there's your answer
so what could be better to help with
free flow of information I've been to a
few geology departments around the world
I think y'all and most of them haven't
Friday they need water here geologists
yeah it's in green we just need it
because when we're doing research
there's not much else going on out there
in the field
you know we're already because hiking
out there in the middle of nowhere we're
just kind of hanging out and we need
something to do at night so part of the
thing with the earth sciences is that
it's really it's not a totally exact
science there's art involved so you have
to be creative so anything that helps
you lose your inhibitions and become
creative and and come up with ideas that
then you can test rigorously but you
still have to have the ideas and so in
some of the sciences I would say that
they're more precise you're more limited
as to what the story is based on your
data but in the earth sciences for the
most part we don't have enough
information really to know everything
we'd like to know about what's going on
so you have to fill in the gaps and that
means you've got to think outside the
box
release your inhibitions and you've got
there is one way to do that